Peggy's 16
[Music]
soé classified intelligence subject
Italy 1943 Operation Torch the British
American invasion of French occupied
North Africa has proved overwhelmingly
successful resistance was virtually
non-existent ejecting the Nazis from
North Africa has cleared the way for an
allied offensive of southern Europe our
intention is to invade Sicily and use
this as a base from which to launch an
invasion of mainland Italy the task will
not be easy Italy has been under fascist
rule since 1922 dictator Benito
Mussolini's forces have ruthlessly
suppressed opposition Nazi troops on
Mussolini's honored guests
things are changing however Allied
bombing food shortages and the spread of
diseases like typhus are taking their
toll on the populace in March 1943
strikes crippled Italy's war production
further civil disobedience seems likely
Mussolini's government looks
increasingly weak for the present our
campaign of disinformation seems to have
convinced Hitler and most of the Nazi
hierarchy that we intend to invade
Sardinia and Greece as soon as Hitler
learns of our plans he's certain to
commit troops to the mainland
probably in substantial numbers but then
spreading the Third Reich too thin is
exactly our aim we need someone who can
prepare the way for the Allies someone
who can fan the flames of resistance and
we need him now briefing complete
[Music]
you
[Music]